MAJORITY OF THE HOUSE.
BRET.
>> Bret: FASCINATING.
PETER DOOCY ON THE HILL.
THANK YOU.
LET'S GET MORE ON THE PROBLEMS
FOR HOUSE REPUBLICANS AND WHAT
THEY ARE FACING HEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US FROM
WASHINGTON.
GOOD EVENING.
YOU HEARD THE STORY.
IT'S KIND OF IN THE THEORETICAL
SENSE BUT WHAT ABOUT THIS
FORCING RYAN TO GET OUT SO THEY
CAN GET DEMOCRATS TO VOTE FOR OR
AGAINST PELOSI.
>> IT'S A CLEVER SOUNDING
STRATAGEM THAT YOU HEAR ABOUT.
SET UP THIS VOTE EVEN THOUGH IT
MAY OR MAY NOT PASS IN ORDER TO
FORCE THE OTHER GUYS TO VOTE A
CERTAIN WAY THAT WOULD BE
POLITICALLY DESCENDANT --
POLITICALLY DISADVANTAGEOUS.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
FORCE-OUT A WELL-REGARDED AND
POPULAR SPEAKER BEFORE HE'S
READY TO GO.
I WOULD BE HESITANT TO BELIEVE
THAT WILL HAPPEN BUT AS WE GO
FORWARD, THE QUESTION OF THE
SPEAKERS INFLUENCE AS A LAME
DUCK ISRAEL.
IF YOU ARE THE SPEAKER AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO RULE ROUND UP
VOTES AND THEY KNOW YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE AROUND AND CAN'T
PUNISH THEM IF THEY VOTE THE
OTHER WAY, BECAUSE HE HAS THE
POWER OF APPOINTMENT TO
COMMITTEES.
IF HE'S LEAVING, THEY MIGHT NOTN
IF HE'S LEAVING, THEY MIGHT NOTT
SO EAGER TO GO ALONG.
THE PROBLEMS FACING HOUSE
REPUBLICANS THIS TIME ARE NOT
REALLY WRAPPED UP IN THE PERSON
WHO IS THE SPEAKER.
THEY ARE WRAPPED UP IN THE
POLITICAL GRAVITY OF A
PRESIDENT'S FIRST MIDTERM AND
THE ISSUES THAT CONFRONT THE
COUNTRY.
>> Bret: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
CLASSIC PAUL RYAN TO SAY I NEED
TO TELL MY CONSTITUENTS I'M NOT
GOING TO BE AROUND INSTEAD OF
WAITING UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION
TO DO THAT.
TALK ABOUT THE PROBLEMS FACING
THOSE REPUBLICANS.
THEY'VE GOT THIS IMMIGRATION
POTENTIAL VOTE WHICH IS ONE OF
THE REASONS THEY FARM BILL WENT
DOWN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S WORTH REMEMBERING THAT THIS
CAUCUS HAD SOME SERIOUS
DIVISIONS WITHIN IT.
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS.
BEFORE PAUL RYAN'S ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT HE WAS LEAVING.
THE IMMIGRATION MEASURE WHICH IS
PROFOUNDLY CONTROVERSIAL ON
WHICH A VOTE MAY BE FORCED IS A
PROBLEM.
THE FATE OF THE FARM BILL, AS
YOU MENTIONED OR AS PETER
MENTIONED, IT'S A PROBLEM.
THEY ARE GOING TO TO GET BACK TO
IT AT SOME POINT.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF PROBLEMS
YOU DON'T PARTICULARLY WANT TO
HAVE AS YOU ARE HEADED INTO A
MIDTERM ELECTION PARTICULARLY A
MIDTERM ELECTION WHICH THE
HISTORIC LAWS OF THE INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT'S PARTY IN A MIDTERM
FIRST PRESIDENTS MIDTERM IS 24
SEATS.
IF 24 SEATS FLIP THIS TIME,
WHICH WOULD BE KIND OF NORMAL,
THE REPUBLICANS LOSE THE HOUSE.
YOU'VE GOT ALL THAT GOING
AGAINST YOU.
YOU HAVE THE MOTIVATION PROVIDED
BY THE PERSONAL ANIMUS TOWARD
TRUMP THAT SO MANY LIBERAL AND
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS FEEL AND THAT
LEADS TO A HIGH HILL TO CLIMB.
THERE ARE SOME NUMBERS THAT MAKE
IT LOOK BETTER, THE GENERIC
BALLOT WHERE YOU ASK IF YOU
WOULD RATHER VOTE FOR DEMOCRAT
OR REPUBLICAN, UNNAMED.
THAT USED TO BE, REPUBLICANS
WERE 16 POINTS UNDERWATER.
IT HAS NARROWED A LOT.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN.
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING HAS
TICKED UP.
IT IS STILL A HUGE CHALLENGE.
>> Bret: YEAH, AN UPHILL
BATTLE FOR REPUBLICANS.